well I just got some great news USA
Today is reporting that Sallie Mae is
expanding from student loans to credit
cards they want to help you out because
everyone in America knows that Sallie
Mae has been such a blessing so far I
mean everything Sallie Mae touches turns
to go aren't you just happy you had that
a woman in your life at some point USA
Today reports Sallie Mae the student
loan provider once sponsored by the
government is expanding into credit
cards because they've not done enough
damage no I said that the company this
month unveiled a suite of three credit
cards aimed at college students recent
graduates and young professionals the
vulnerable in the naive no just kidding
not really it's new cards offer rewards
for Responsible financial behavior which
would not include getting one of the
cards this is so stupid they come 18
months after the company introduced new
personal loans to go along with their
student loan business the cards have no
annual fees for the first six to twelve
months and then they go to fifteen to
twenty five almost twenty six percent
bring your interest rates company's goal
is to diversify its business to meet the
needs of our customers after high school
in college because we hadn't sucked all
of their blood left butt blood out yet
there's a few drops left want to make
sure we get what you're owed so the the
cards are called the Ignite card the
accelerate card and the Evolve card
sounds like a bunch of people sat around
an ad agency and named these stupid butt
cards to me
the chief marketing officer Donna Vieira
for Sallie Mae says they recommend
establishing credit during college the
secured card that requires an initial
down payment as collateral this is this
is this one's fabulous right listen to
this quote college is a good time to
make those small financial mistakes so
that you can learn going forward scrap
you can't make this up make them you
don't wanna make this small mistake you
won't make the small mistakes what your
young larger mistakes later make them
when you're a little older and the
stakes might be higher this is the quote
that's hilarious so brought to you by
the people who have changed your life
for the better said no one ever
about Sallie Mae I mean if you ever met
anybody went you know what Sally Mae is
just the best organization they just
have loved on me my life is better
because I've interacted with selling me
I'm just so thankful Sallie Mae's on the
planet the best thing that ever happened
to me in my life was Sally freaking Mae
I have just never heard this I've never
heard this from a single human and so
they're going to continue to find ways
to extract see the problem is that the
banking industry has forgotten somewhere
along the lines all they do is when you
look at these products and you take them
apart on the inside and you see what
they're making on them they're making
Bank no pun intended on these products
they're getting filthy stinking rich on
them and when they sit down and they see
how much money they can extract from
your life by launching you know the
evolve the ignite and the accelerate
card oh give me a break
geez when they see that when they see
how much money they can make they can't
keep themselves their hogs going to the
to the trough they just can't keep from
belying up to the bar
and order another round cuz they just
know they can take you to the cleaners
and you know and and then they try to
figure out a way in their little minds
that it's somehow good for the customer
but they know they know they know
they're screwing you they they
understand overdraft fees and credit
card fees or where banks make all their
money it's where they make all their
money the overdraft fee business in
America with bank with commercial banks
is in the billions and billions and
billions of dollars and the credit card
interest rates those two things alone
keep the stinking places open and
they're sucking the blood out of the
very marrow of your bones I mean their
financial vampires and Sallie Mae is
looking at this see it was formed
originally to make and service
government-sponsored loans and it was
originally a government-sponsored like
Fannie Mae was that's why it's called
Sallie Mae it was a government-sponsored
organization for the purposes of student
loans well the government cut them loose
because they sucked so bad at managing
the student loan epic plague debacle and
navient is now running the show on that
stuff but Sallie Mae's got the old ones
and so they're no longer
government-sponsored so they go into
personal loans and now they come out so
really basically what they are is just
another stinkin Bank and a very large
one and one with bad motives because
from day one they've screwed every
customer they've touched and so now they
have a credit card I mean really you
just when company's very mission
statement says stuff like we are here to
expand shareholder wealth that's their
mission statement let me help you with
that
that means you the customer are not in
their mission you are not their mission
you are their prey and they are the
predator
run little gazelle run the cheetah is
coming he wants to eat you for lunch
this is a Hansel and Gretel Sally may
think about Hansel Gretel the witch in
the woods right and she captures the
children and puts them in the oven right
this is Sallie Mae she's the witch in
the woods she's gonna put your little
butt in an oven now at 24 26 percent
interest on a credit card because our
our goal is to help college students and
everyone that believes that do the Hokey
Pokey right now give me a break you've
got to be kidding me
sorry Sallie Mae you still suck